satya Tonio is a town in Alton age Oh
it faces many of the same problems as
other small towns in Portugal there are
more elderly than young people there are
few activities and many people are
leaving but these plastic structures
have allowed Hsiao Tieh Tonio to prosper
for the past few years this region has
thrived
thanks to year round fruit growing it's
also attracted workers particularly from
Asia it meets our own process the
prakruti it's a natural development
between supply and demand that then
creates a market which is often boosted
by word-of-mouth
wacka-wacka what is in desert the
Growers Association can't explain why so
many Asians want to come to Portugal
late in the day we get the answer at
hsiao-tieh Tonio's Market Square many
workers meet here including pal winders
Singh from India he used to live in
Denmark the other countries are very
strict you know like Germany Denmark and
Swedish unity I got I need the visa to
stay here but here I can stay you know
without the visa and all that and that's
what I can I can apply for the permanent
residence here and that's why so many
workers are from Nepal Thailand Pakistan
and India many have already tried to
start a new life in other EU countries
market Singh from India spent two years
in Hamburg he couldn't find work legally
so he moved to Portugal where he's been
for two years for this family yo time
Alaric II those grants okay you go stag
my wife and child are here and I like it
when other people from India or Pakistan
have worked a long time they get a
Portuguese passport and then move to
another country like Britain Germany or
Belgium Inglot hora Alemannia Bal Chico
workers have to wait six or seven years
to get the documents they need some like
Malik want to stay in Portugal after
getting a passport even though they earn
no more than 800 euros per month
they say the calm and secure life in the
southwest of the EU is worth more than
money